le centre ville de montréal deviendra
bientôt un laboratoire à ciel ouvert 200
antennes 5g vont être installées à
partir du printemps 2021 c'est la
première entente entre une ville et les
compagnies de télécommunications canada
rogers telus vidéotron et bim field vont
se partager ce périmètre d'environ
quatre kilomètres carrés même si
plusieurs ont déjà commencé à installer
des antennes ailleurs sur le territoire
comme la réglementation fédérale le
permet pour moi ouais c'est important ce
qui s'avère le train d'aller plus vite
en espérant évidemment qu'on est
toujours est elle nous donnait préservé
nous aurions souhaité comme certaines
villes européennes de pouvoir déterminer
la manière dont le singe allaient se
déployer sur nos territoires
malheureusement ça n'a pas été acceptée
c'est pour ça que nous avons travaillé
sur ce projet pilote la ville autorise
les entreprises à utiliser le mobilier
urbain comme les feux de circulation ou
les abribus et en échange elle pourra se
servir des flux de données
si par exemple nous avons une
information plus rapide sur des
difficultés de circulation une
intersection à cause des données notre
capacité de réaction va être plus rapide
mais ce projet est décriée par les
opposants à la 5g acceptation ils
réclament un moratoire comme certaines
métropoles européennes l'ont décidé mais
ce sont des choix politique et non
scientifique selon cette spécialiste
c'est pas des décisions qui sont fondés
sur le fait qu'on connaisse un danger il
faudrait pas l'interdire que dans
quelques villes mais partout s'il y
avait danger avéré et elle rappelle que
les ondes de la 5g ne traverse pas la
peau montréal s'engage quant à elle à la
transparence totale sur son projet
pilote y compris sur les études que
pourrait mener la santé publique
il devrait y avoir à terme environ 60000
antenne 5g sur le territoire montréalais
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal